I confess I had the idea that David
Whelan should give our convocation talk
this time so I could thank him in public
so also share with you some things I
know about him
which you will also learn by listening
to him talk in a minute his students
know that he is learned and witty and
good-natured and inspiring and difficult
he takes special pride in the last thing
he thinks of himself is somewhat
melancholy the truth is he brims with
happiness and love and joy some of us
who work with him closely now for a long
time 2004 is when he first got
affiliated with the provost office under
Bob Blackstock I personally began to
consult him almost immediately after I
got here he like I said of mark his firm
and clear in his judgments and he's calm
in the middle of a clamor such a
valuable thing
he has strong principles and he can
explain them he keeps them in mind and
yet he can pay attention to the details
that also govern what you do in any
particular situation he can calm himself
he can see those details in their true
life that's not easy to do things go
wrong trouble got to decide right now
don't know enough I've done that with
him now for 15 years but before that I
used to talk to him all the time because
we began to run a seminar me and him and
Mark and a few others over the years to
figure out how on earth do you manage to
college it's complicated how do you get
unity when the methodology is to argue
and disagree all the time how do you
cope with having an old mission in a new
day how do you get 19-year olds to
behave themselves or for that matter
seniors 21 year olds
we've talked those subjects through
exhaustively
we don't really have any thoughts about
it that we can separate from the
thoughts of the other one when he came
to me not for the first time to ask to
be relieved of the provost job he asked
in a somewhat different tone and I could
tell that maybe he meant it I said so
you mean at this time and he said I do I
have to do this he didn't but I said
okay I want to negotiate and he said all
right I said dad you have to keep some
position that keeps you close to the
council's of the college because we need
you there knowing what's going on you
have to do anything except give your
advice I'll give him things to do later
he he wants to teach more so he's going
to I said you're gonna be called I think
he changed it though he's now to be
called associate vice president for
curriculum he said what does that mean
and I said that's the beauty of it it
doesn't mean anything
Latitude there's no significant success
that we've had here at this college
since I've been here of which he is not
hard it's so urgently necessary that he
continued to help up where I work
because it wouldn't be as good without
him and he has agreed and I've never had
a better colleague david whele
well sometimes we're honored beyond our
deserving in our friends parents are
practiced at panic they live in crisis
we eat stress for breakfast in revenge
we master the art of embarrassing our
children preferably in public a
presumably graduating senior here right
now will have to endure my practice of
this embarrassment art for just a minute
as I write as I recount an episode in
his young life of some 21 years ago an
episode in which he began to see the
world I had never heard of night terrors
before becoming a parent the unmarried
here might think that being a parent is
a night terror
and thinking so would be an
understandable mistake but night terrors
are a strange phenomenon in which a very
young child is roused by comfortless
paroxysm 'he's
a screaming terror in the middle of the
night not a nightmare not a sudden need
for comfort and security night terror is
an eruption of mad unassailable panicked
horror proof against any amount of
parental comforting caressing cooing
bouncing singing even a mother's breast
fails to break the spell of
insensibility and relieve the anguish I
am sure of course that someone has
studied and explained all this and I'm
equally sure that the explanation when
one is trapped and the experience is
useless one night many years ago in a
house not far from where we are right
now my wife and I were awakened by the
screaming of our then youngest child
seized with these very strange terrors
he was neither asleep nor awake his eyes
were open but saw nothing his infant
sinews were taught but thrashing ropes
we'd seen it before and we knew the
prayerful despair or we were in for and
of course that was nothing to the
torture he was unreachable undergoing if
they can awaken then all will be well if
they can come out of the cul-de-sac in
which they're trapped these children can
be comforted loved returned to rest but
they will not awaken desperate for an
expedient I prowled the ground floor of
our house away from the other bedrooms
so his screams might not awakened or
terrify his siblings I'm not sure why
I'm not sure it was even a good idea in
the abstract but holding him in my arms
I went out the front door and took this
screaming irrational animal into the 3
a.m. night air no change I'm sure the
neighbors were delighted by the novelty
by the novelty of infant screams in the
street in the middle of the night but
under the force of some weird
inspiration and without any theory about
what might happen I walked up to a tree
took his hand and held it against the
bark he stopped as I slowly moved his
palm against the tree stroking it as it
were he turned looked at the tree and
stopped it was awake now I do not have a
sophisticated neuropsychological
explanation for why and what happened I
cannot even insert that is awakening was
caused by rather than simply accompanied
by the touching of the tree although to
tell the truth subsequent experience has
seemed to confirm the connection but
what it seemed at the time and what it
seems now is that touching the tree
somehow allowed reality the world the
universe of actually existing things to
break through and liberate an infant
mind trapped in some kind of endless
unreal loop of object less alarm all the
things his senses customarily conveyed
to him his mother's touch and voice the
walls and floors and furniture of the
house my clumsy coddling none of this
had the novelty or the radical
unfamiliarity and impact that tree bark
had in the outdoor night tree bark was
the shock that broke the block the
terror built our account all this not to
suggest that our fears can be dissolved
by becoming tree huggers or that bark
beats coffee as a stimulant or even that
if you value sleep celibacy is the
answer
rather
is it is it wildly inappropriate for a
father at 11 to say celibacy is
underrated rather I mention all this the
episode because the episode captures
perfectly how hard it is to wake up
metaphorically speaking and see reality
thoroughly how despite our intelligence
and Precision's and conceptual agility
we mostly we mostly move in something
like a dream or a fog even if we do not
do so in terror people ordinarily live
in a state of dim or partial
comprehension of the world and even of
their own lives the experience we've all
it's universal we have all had this
experience we take for granted that we
grasp or understand a thing only to find
that our hand suddenly touches it
metaphorically and we suddenly see it as
if for the first time I realize of
course there is absolutely nothing new
or original in this observation why says
any dillard does death so catch us by
surprise and while of we still and
always want waking we should amass half
dressed in long lines like tribesmen and
shake gourds at each other to wake up
instead we watch television and Misha
missed the show standing half dressed
and shaking gourds at each other maybe
an odd image for liberal education but
so be it
this is exactly what it does are
imprisoned and insensible souls are
brought somewhat reluctantly I think
into right
ignition note the word read cognition of
the world of God and of man not entirely
not exhaustively
not even satisfactorily but what we are
attempting to do here is to overcome the
native slumbers of our brilliant species
and see if we can help each other
enter reality itself the paradox is an
arresting one or at least it should be
how is it that so magnificent a thing as
man described reportedly by God himself
as a little lower than the Angels should
be so impenetrably dense Walker Percy
famously asked why is it possible to
learn more in ten minutes about the Crab
Nebula in Taurus which is six thousand
light years away then you presently know
about yourself even though you've been
stuck with yourself your whole life this
perfectly joins the brilliance to the
density in a similar vein my students
have learned not to reply fine or well
when I to my query
how are you because if they do I'm
likely to ask how in the name of the
seven mad gods they can call themselves
well when they are two decades old and
still in training for release into the
world cats dogs pigs naked mole-rats
theo conforming hetero sevilla day that
they are all strike jauntily into the
world less than a year into their
nativity and here you are I tell them
meekly sitting behind desks wondering
what will be on the test
professorial rantings aside the query
really rests on the most serious
possible grounds the same being
brilliant enough to grasp the physics of
Brunelleschi's dome or through printed
language enter into a kind of
conversation with people long dead is so
dense and enamored of his dream world
that it takes decades to lure him into
reality it takes families and
institutions and bottomless effort and
resource to usher man into something
approximating a comprehension of the
given world the universe of things not
fashioned by his own wishes assumptions
tastes or imaginings including by the
way the works of others imaginations the
paradox is real we are brilliant
beyond calculating and dense beyond
measure at the same time almost in the
same way and even about the same things
so what and how is it that a liberal
education is likened to shaking the
shaking the awakening gourd well
certainly not in the tendentious
ideological sense the the metaphor of
awakening now is made to bear nor in
some sentimental sense that either
pursues enlightenment like a drug that's
though whoa man school of sentimentality
or the equally sentimental sense that
thinks of Education as power rather the
awakening that liberal education pursues
is slow gradual 2/3 complete before
anyone even begins to realize what is
underway it has the character oddly of a
byproduct resulting from a thousand
difficult or the fuddling studies
inquiries conversations and battles many
seemingly unrelated to each other
liberal education awakens us to reality
in a way that seems indirect sideways in
an elaborate dance where the object
and that it's truth is not transmitted
or tackled but wooed and won if Latin
had a verb for doing liberal education
it would be ad opponent passive in form
active and meaning which of course means
something both John Henry Newman points
out the counterintuitive yet at the same
time obvious fact that we learn about
reality not by swallowing it whole but
by breaking it up into pieces we call
disciplines we break it apart study it
bit by bit and then reintegrate all
these bits into a comprehensive
assimilating unified and expanding
understanding of what is or at a minimum
we acquire the habit of an assimilating
unifying comprehension of what is the
bits matter who can truly grasp what is
real in cognizant of the principles of
what we call economics or physics do you
really think you even see the world if
you do not grasp history or that wild
pursuit of beauty we call art how
susceptible are you to simple human
reality if you are not at least
minimally alive to the principles of
politics our biology and ethics just
decorations mental doilies or wallpaper
is philosophy really the place where one
scratch is largely irrelevant thought
experiment inches or is it where much of
everything else comes home to roost and
what about theology well
I rest my case the bits matter we need a
plurality of them the dirty little
secret about liberal education as Newman
understood is that the disciplines exist
necessarily in order for us to
understand reality broadly study just
one even a most important one and one
becomes a misshapen grotesque a hammer
to whom everything looks like a nail
to be sure we are not talking I am NOT
talking about liberal education making
one well-rounded as if the object of
Education were corpulence the
superficial of knowledge of the
dilettante is not the point the
enlightened capacity to see reality
itself is the object here but as new and
also points out liberal education does
not rest in these disciplines
it depends upon them that rises well
above them and and I have to admit this
can rub us that is academics quite the
wrong way academics are out of necessity
happy idolaters we love our own
disciplines to distraction and are
jealous for their honor a moment ago
during that little litany of disciplines
I was mentioning every professor here
was listening for his or her own
and if it was not mentioned that fact
was likely noticed as if I failed to
introduce someone's spouse at a social
event this love is necessary and
defensible as such devotion makes
possible the long study necessary for
expertise but loving to distraction has
its own dangers etymologically
distraction means pulling apart we so
love our disciplines that jealous for
their honor and priority we are often on
the verge of pulling apart the very
thing liberal learning that brought the
disciplines into being in the first
place and that needs them all so
entirely disciplines exist finally not
for their own sake but in service of
something higher the integrating habit
of mind whereby we are all moved to
wakefulness wakefulness to reality and
that's with an uppercase R and so we
perpetual sophomores wise fools all plod
gradually on studying and arguing and
forgetting a thousand things any one of
which deserves a lifetime of wonder and
devotion and we slowly awaken to find we
are not the insensible braying donkeys
we were just a few years ago it's not
that we are all that wise to be sure but
we can tell that was what was once a
two-dimensional surface now possesses
some death it may be dimly seen at best
but it is there or to change the figure
our hand has been touched to the tree
and as Shakespeare knows we then find
tongues in trees books in the running
Brooks sermons in stones and good in
everything thank you
you